we are all pretty sad that attack on
titan is ending soon but don't worry we
got you covered because in today's video
we'll be covering top 12 animes similar
to attack on titan number 12. black
bullet
black bullet shares more than just a
post-apocalyptic setting with attack on
titan it also has characters that feel
like they will never escape their
circumstances as well as many similar
plot devices and themes this anime is
about a post-apocalyptic japan where
most of the humans have been infected
with the gastria virus and turned into
monsters what is left of mankind now
lives within the monolith walls sounds
familiar right to combat this threat
people are trained to become weapons
known as promoters or civil officers
these promoters work in teams with the
initiators young girls with superhuman
abilities black bullet revolves around
the team of venju an initiator and
rentaro a promoter as they go on
missions to fight the growing threat of
gastria in their hometown of tokyo
number 11. fate apocrypha
fate apocrypha is a unique take on the
fate series instead of the usual battle
royale among seven mages it features two
teams of seven masters and their
servants fighting against each other in
order to obtain something called the
holy grail the only problem none of them
know what exactly it does just like an
attack on titan these characters are not
your typical heroes either which makes
things all that more compelling as you
watch them fight to try and achieve
their goals there are many mysteries
within both anime shows that keep the
viewers interested until the very end
number 10. claymore
you unwittingly led me right to your own
death
claymore is set in the world where the
shape-shifting demons known as yoma eat
humans one of these monsters arrives in
rocky's village and kills his family but
before it can kill rocky a claymore
claire appears and saves him the
claymores are half human half yoma
hybrid warriors with the express purpose
of exterminating these monsters the
story then follows rocky and claire as
they travel from down to town defeating
yomas along the way both claymore and
attack on titan are very similar both
are set in medieval times where humans
are fighting against man-eating monsters
also both are quite violent and make use
of swords and combat if you are a fan of
aot this is surely the anime for you
number nine blue exorcist you are not a
human being rin
you are the son of a demon born by a
human blue exorcist follows rin okumara
who appears to be an ordinary teenager
but his world is turned upside down when
he finds out that he is the son of an
actual satan not wanting to join his
father he starts his training in order
to become an exorcist the similarities
between attack on titan and blue
exorcist can be found literally
everywhere we will only mention a few to
avoid spoilers both protagonists are 15
year old boys both of them discover that
they have similar powers to the enemy
they are fighting and their enemies have
been a threat to humanity since forever
both characters aaron and ren also have
the same voice actor in the english
version we can all agree that nothing
can beat attack on titan but you should
give blue exorcist a try it may surprise
you number eight elfin lead
okay i will be honest with you guys
elfin lead doesn't really have that much
in common with attack on titan but it's
an exceptional anime and we are sure
that a lot of aot fans will find it
entertaining lucy is a special breed of
human referred to as declonius born with
a short pair of horns and invisible
telekinetic hands she was severely
abused by human beings and subsequently
wants to murder them all as revenge
elfin lead involves some heavy themes
like revenge jealousy regret and the
value of humanity this anime is
certainly not everyone's cup of tea but
if you've liked what you've heard so far
definitely go and check it out number
seven full metal alchemist brotherhood
[Music]
in order for something to be obtained
something of equal value must be lost
this is the main rule of alchemy and
full metal alchemist brotherhood this
anime is about two brothers edward and
al who are talented state alchemists
that have lost their body parts due to a
failed attempt at human transmutation
three years of searching later the
brothers seek the philosopher's stone a
mythical relic that allows an alchemist
to overcome the law of equivalent
exchange attack on titan is very similar
in terms of how it handles its
characters and both shows are full of
death and unexpected plot twists it is
one of the best rated anime shows ever
so what are you waiting for go and watch
it number six serif of the end the only
reason i'm here is to get revenge on
those blood sucking freaks with the
appearance of a mysterious virus that
kills everyone above the age of 13 power
hungry vampires emerge in order to
subjugate society
because of that young children are now
at their mercy with some becoming
blood-sucking creatures themselves
yuichiro is the only one who is able to
escape his fate he later joins the
imperial demon army a military unit
tasked with killing all vampires in
japan alongside other characters the
group has to figure out how they're
going to defeat this new threat number 5
god eater
[Music]
this anime is about a world where
creatures known as origami are taking
over the planet on top of that people
also have to worry about getting eaten
by them the only ones who can fight
against these monsters are the god
eaters humans who have been found to be
compatible with one of the living
origami weapons made to harm and devour
other origami attack on titan and god
ear both show off very similar themes
there's always an impending doom be it
titans or origami that makes things all
the more suspenseful once you start
watching god eater is not interesting
just because it shares similarities with
aot but also due to how many characters
within the show aren't typical heroes
which brings something fresh to your
usual action-packed anime number 4.
helsing ultimate
if you're a fan of attack on titan
helsing ultimate is one of the animes
that you'll definitely enjoy watching
instead of fighting titans the heroes
within this anime are hunting down
different types of creatures including
werewolves and zombies none of which can
be easily defeated it's about an
organization known as helsing that
utilizes its own vampire alucard to
fight against other creatures alucard is
a ruthless and ridiculously strong
vampire that fights his own kind along
with everything else who tries to oppose
helsing other than monsters trying to
destroy humanity this anime doesn't
share that much with attack on titan but
still we urge you to go and watch it you
won't be disappointed number three
castlevania pack and go
and do not look back
castlevania is actually an american
anime based on a series of japanese
video games with the same name the anime
features trevor belmont as the main
protagonist on a quest to stop the evil
dracula who seeks to destroy humanity
following the execution of his wife lisa
castlevania is the first ever video game
adaptation to get a very good score and
ratings from various critics it may not
sound compelling at first glance but
castlevania does have some great action
scenes which makes it worth watching
number 2 tokyo ghoul
ken kaneki is a boy who goes on a date
with rize a girl he met in cafe however
rize is not exactly who she seems she is
actually a monster that eats people a
ghoul kaneki soon becomes a half ghoul
and he is dragged into a conflict with
many others like him he is forced to
live in two worlds one where he is seen
as monsters and another where he is
considered human attack on titan has a
lot of similar themes when it comes to
its characters both animes are set in a
cruel world and the main characters are
forced to find a way to survive number
1. kabaneri of the iron fortress
out of all the animes on this list this
one is by far the most similar to attack
on titan horrific creatures emerge from
a mysterious virus ripping through the
flesh of humans to save their
never-ending appetite to combat this
people have built fortresses around
their cities in order to protect them
from these monsters wow that sounds
familiar but on top of that the anime is
actually made by the same studio that
made the first three seasons of attack
on titan and we can all agree that
attack on titan looks amazing well i
don't think i need to persuade you
anymore close this video and go watch
kabaneri right now but before you leave
hitting a like button would be great and
you can also subscribe for more anime
content like this okay you can leave now
bye